breasts come in different shapes and
sizes but there's one thing they all
have in common they are unique to humans
more than 5,000 mammalian species
inhabit this planet yet homo sapiens are
the only life forms with permanent
breasts some may call this human anomaly
sexy but it also begs the question why
are human breasts so big and were they
an evolutionary mistake every other
mammal develops temporary breasts during
ovulation and or nursing basically their
purpose is to produce milk so once the
milk is gone the breasts disappear but
this isn't the case for female humans
whose breasts formed during puberty not
pregnancy so at some point in our
evolution something changed but what for
example in 1987 biologist Tim Caro
explored seven existing theories on this
subject
one was that breasts allowed mothers to
nurse newborns from their hip giving
them more mobility to multitask but it
doesn't explain why breasts stick around
after the nursing stage is over perhaps
the most popular idea was first proposed
by Charles Darwin and later explored by
zoologist Desmond Morris in his 1967
book the naked ape in it Morris suggests
that breasts evolved as a sex symbol to
replace the swelling rear end of other
female primates during ovulation once
our ancestors started walking upright
the sexual organs were no longer as
obvious to spot so males had no way of
knowing when a female was sexually
mature and breasts may have formed as a
result this theory would at least
explain why women's chest swell during
puberty but it still can't explain why
they stick around after menopause let's
take a closer look at the human breast
the big difference is that it contains
more fat than other female mammals the
fat fills out the breast tissue giving
it shape sort of like milk but permanent
human breasts can become so large it can
cause back and chest pain this is why
many women get breast reductions more
than 61,000 received a breast reduction
in
sixteen in the US alone but breasts
aren't only uncomfortable for some they
can also be deadly breast cancer is the
number one cause of cancer-related
deaths in women worldwide it affects
roughly one and a half million women
each year and it killed five hundred and
seventy thousand of them in 2015
yet as far as scientists can tell breast
cancer is not common among other
primates this could be because the risk
of cancer increases with age and other
primates don't live long enough to
develop breast cancer or perhaps it
could have something to do with the
permanent breast tissue itself cancer is
more common in rapidly dividing tissue
every time cells are born and die there
is an opportunity within the cell cycle
to make mistakes in repairing DNA and
essentially a cell with mistakes and
become a cancer as though breast tissue
divides at a rapid pace so is a greater
opportunity to make mistakes that may
explain why removing both breasts
reduces a woman's risk of breast cancer
by 95% of course breasts have
established their place in human culture
and society they can make women feel
wanted liberated or empowered and
they've helped build entire empires
based simply on their power to attract
it looks like for better or worse human
breasts are here to stay
[Music]